hey 42 here what have I told you that 8%
of your DNA isn't actually
yours what have I said it was given to
you by a strange almost alien life form
one that still lives amongst us right
now don't worry I'll explain all in just
a minute but first I want to ask you a
question imagine you wake up tomorrow
morning and turn on the TV to be shocked
by the breaking news that every virus in
the world has been eradicated how would
you feel
I'm willing to bet you'd be somewhat
elated in an instant you'd be free of
the fear you've held in the back of your
throat your entire life that you could
catch a killer virus Ebola HIV influenza
the list goes on you might merily skip
outside and give the pavement a good
lick and maybe your neighbor's face for
good measure safe in the knowledge that
no ill can come of your Reckless
lopon but what have I told you that your
relief would be replaced with Dread in
in the coming years as a series of
unexpected but deadly consequences arise
amidst this new virus-free world what
have I told you that you'd soon be
begging for the return of those once
maligned pathogens don't believe me
watch until the end of this video and
you'll discover why eradicating viruses
could be the biggest and last mistake we
ever
make viruses are everywhere and I don't
mean like pretam Manas in London
everywhere I mean that viruses literally
cover every inch of our world from the
deepest depths of the ocean to the
highest mountain peak and from the most
Barren desert to the densest rainforests
there is no corner of our planet where
viruses cannot be found there in Every
Breath You Take Korean scientists tested
the air in a forest and found that each
cubic meter of air contained up to 40
million
viruses that fact might make you feel
icky and only give rise to your desire
to eradicate them from our planet but
don't be so Hasty you should be grateful
for those gross organisms to which
you're playing host because without them
you probably wouldn't be here right now
in the grand tapestry of Life viruses
have not just been a Fred but a master
Weaver intricately shaping the very
fabric of our existence it's a story
that begins at the dawn of life itself
in the murky primordial Waters of
ancient Earth viruses in their simplest
form are genetic material encased in a
protein coat they are so primitive that
they straddle the line between living
and non-living unable to reproduce
without a host this ancient survival
mechanism suggests that viruses may have
been amongst the first forms of genetic
material possibly co-evolving with the
earliest forms of cellular
life
I remember one time I was fishing on
Lake Guntersville in Northeast Alabama
when suddenly this warline with an
attitude was on my hook it near enough
pulled me into the lake but I grabbed my
rod and managed to reel a Teflon
Troublemaker in it was one of my
proudest moments oh wait sorry that
actually happened on fishing Clash it
all just felt so real fishing Clash
brings the world of fishing right to
your couch and I mean the world you can
cast your line on the coast of Florida
the Amazon River lch Ness Cape Town the
Nile and so many more and to make things
even sweeter or saltier I suppose is the
expansive variety of different fish you
can catch at each location I always need
my game to have a competive edge to keep
me coming back and fishing Clash brings
this in boatloads with events happening
daily and weekly and leaderboards to
keep on top of I particularly love the
PVP Jewel mode which lets me go
head-to-head to see who can catch the
most and biggest fish if you're just
starting out and not catching fish as
big as you'd like I'd recommend
purchasing powerups in the shop my
favorite is is the luck power up oh and
don't forget to improve your laws to
catch the best fish by leveling up your
laws you also level up meaning more fish
and more fun to be caught download the
game by using my link in the description
box below or scan the QR code you see on
the screen and use my special gift code
fish with Aaron to get a special $20
value award including a unique avatar
for free in Earth's early life soup
viruses played a unique role gene
mutations can happen vertically when
genes are passed from parent to
offspring but viruses are special in
that they enable horizontal Gene
transfer think of them as cuers carrying
tiny packets of genetic information from
one host to
another this process would have
catalyzed the evolution of early
organisms increasing the diversity and
speed of the evolution process and this
same process went on to affect the
evolution of larger organisms such as
insects and animals later in Earth's
timeline the evidence of virus's ancient
Origins and their role in shaping life
is etched into our very DNA I mentioned
at the start of this video that 8% of
your DNA is not yours well that 8% is
composed of endogenous retroviruses
remnants of ancient viral infections so
viruses have made us who we are today we
don't know how humans would have turned
out without viruses but we'd be
radically different if we existed at all
and it's not just animal life that has
reaped the benefit of what viruses have
sown they've played a pivotal role in
the evolution of plants plant viruses
have shown to confer resistance to
certain pests and diseases improving
crop resilience without this modern day
plants might be too weak to survive in
our changing world and we might have
succumbed to famine by
now
so by this point I'm probably changing
your view a little on viruses but let's
still answer that question what would we
have to do to eradicate them all and
what would happen if we did let's start
with the how eradicating all viruses
would be an undertaking of unprecedented
scale and complexity it's not just about
developing a cure or vaccine for every
known virus which in itself is a close
to impossible task no it's about
completely removing every single viral
particle from every corner of the planet
from the depths of the oceans to Taylor
Swift's underwear draw that's right it's
going to be a huge challenge imagine
Nanobots capable of identifying and
destroying viruses at a molecular level
or perhaps some form of global
atmospheric filtration system that could
remove viral particles from the air we'd
need similar systems for water and soil
of course then we'd need to purify every
living organism which could be done
using some mythical super vaccine
providing we wait a generation or two
for all the current carriers to die
off but even if we could develop a
universal vaccine for every known virus
it wouldn't even scratch to surface for
a start we only know about a fraction of
them highly speculative estimates put
that number at about 1% so 99% of all
viruses are unknown to
science then there's the fact that
viruses evolve constantly and rapidly
besides say you had this magical vaccine
how the holy hell are we going to
inoculate every living thing it's not
just humans everything would need to be
inoculated and I mean everything can you
imagine trying to chase down 20 million
ferrets to stab them with needles if
such a vaccine was created let's just
assume that it can adapt itself to all
unknown and future strains of viruses
the most effective method of
disseminating it would be by spreading
it throughout the global Water Supply
that way it would eventually make its
way into the water cycle and rain down
on crops which would be eaten directly
or indirectly by almost every living
creature now this is obviously grossly
oversimplified and the reality of such
an operation would be insurmountably
complex but let's just say for
argument's sake that we manage The
Impossible we inoculate every living
creature we get out the de all and scrub
every Rock and every leaf we purify
every particle of air using the most
advanced graphine filter imaginable you
get the idea after doing all of this and
a lot more besides planet Earth is
officially 100% virus free what happens
next at this point it would be an
appropriate metaphor to say that our
species has now crossed the rubic comp
because for reasons that will soon
become clear there is no turning back we
have no choice but to march on a squeaky
clean Rome but what will be awaiting us
will it be a virus for Utopia or a
vision of hell initially it might seem
like heaven imagine waking up in a world
where the constant threat of viral
pandemics no longer looms over Humanity
gusta news might have to talk about
something interesting for a change
hospitals and Health Care Systems will
be relieved of a significant portion of
their cases no more HIV flu or
hepatitis the psychological impact would
be profound without fear of contracted
illness socializing would feel easier
and physical contact would be employed
more
liberally just imagine being able to
take the tube without worrying of every
Ruddy face traveler around you as
carrying a dreaded
cold people would take fewer sick days
resulting in a worldwide productivity
uptick without livestock Contracting
viruses the global food supply would
become more stable and slightly
cheaper and perhaps the greatest benefit
would be that without viruses to worry
about medical research could refocus all
of its attention on curing nonviral
Killers such as cancer dementia and
other genetic diseases but as the
initial wave of euphoria Fades cracks
begin to appear in our virus free
Utopia the first sign of trouble comes
from the natural world without viruses
to keep their populations in check
certain species of bacteria start to
proliferate
uncontrollably these bacteria once
harmless become opportunistic pathogens
causing outbreaks of diseases we've
never seen before our antibiotics
already stretched fin by years of
overuse proved to be utterly ineffective
against these new
threats in the oceans the absence of
marine viruses destroys the marine food
web to give you some kind of idea every
day viruses kill about 20% of all
bacteria in the ocean and all that dead
bacteria provides a food source for
microscopic marine life and that's a
delicate balance you just don't want to
upset phytoplankton usually kept in
check check by viruses now blooms
uncontrollably leading to the depletion
of the ocean's oxygen creating vast dead
zones where no fish can survive suddenly
a primary source of protein for billions
of people around the globe is threatened
furthermore phytoplankton acts like a
carbon sponge absorbing CO2 from the
atmosphere therefore a huge algi Bloom
could reverse the greenhouse gas effect
causing the climate to rapidly cool
some of you might think that's a good
thing after all isn't that what every
politician and Swedish teenager has been
banging on about all this time well not
quite because not only would the algae
absorb CO2 it would also increase the
albo that's the reflectivity of the
Earth's surface which means more solar
energy would be bounced back into space
so the Earth absorbs less of the sun's
heat the result could be a runaway
cooling event Paving the way for another
Ice Age on on land ecosystems begin to
unravel in alarming ways insects crucial
for the pollination of countless plant
species are severely impacted without
viruses to naturally regulate their
populations species like the aphid
explode in numbers leading to widespread
crop damage and A disruption of the
natural food
chain in humans the consequences are
equally dire our immune systems having
evolved in a world teaming with viruses
begin to malfunction without viruses to
train and regulate our immune responses
we see a rise in autoimmune diseases our
bodies lacking an external enemy will
start to attack themselves conditions
like multiple sclerosis rheumatoid
aritis and type 1 diabetes become
rampant now you've heard of the human
microbiome but have you heard of the
virome there are strains of viruses
inside you and on your skin right now
that have been with you your enti entire
life your silent
passengers we think of viruses as bad
but most of the viruses in your vome are
harmless and even
beneficial they influence your
microbiome and complement your immune
system by reducing populations of
pathogenic bacteria and harmful viruses
in your body so getting rid of your
virro would have profound and Untold
consequences but the most alarming
effect of all at least long term comes
in the form of genetic
stagnation we think of evolution as a
slow process taking place over millions
of years but a significant and Sudden
Change in the environment like removing
all viruses would cause all living
things to exhibit noticeable changes
within just a century or two of course
animals with shorter lifespans would be
the first to exhibit change but given
enough time human DNA would also adapt
future Generations are born into a world
where genetic diversity is severely
stagnated making our species more
susceptible to new diseases and
environmental changes in a cruel twist
of fate Humanity realizes that in its
quest to create a virus free Utopia it
has instead fashioned The Fragile World
teetering on the brink of ecological and
genetic collapse the irony is not lost
in our attempt to outsmart nature we
have only underscored our own
vulnerability and in pursuing a perfect
world we lose sight of the imperfection
that made our world perfect as I already
mentioned scientists think that viruses
have been on Earth since the dawn of
life itself so to boil it all down we
just shouldn't mess with what's worked
for billions of
years okay we've screwed up crop
failures are leading to mass famine
we've just triggered a new Ice Age and
our bodies are attacking themselves
can't we simply tuck our tail between
our legs and Retreat back over the
Rubicon can't we simply reintroduce
viruses and hope ecological balance is
restored well there's a reason I
described eradicating all viruses as
Crossing the Rubicon because there is no
way back at least there's no easy way
especially if was sans's viruses for a
prolonged period of time the longer it
is the worse it will be upon their
return it's not just a matter of
sprinkling viruses back into the
atmosphere and the oceans the ecological
systems having developed for decades
without these viral Regulators are no
longer prepared for their reintroduction
to take just one example if we
reintroduced the viruses that previously
controlled aphid populations aphids now
with weakened immune systems might
experience Mass die offs and that would
be bad although a pest they provide a
vital food source for many small
Predators a similar outcome could happen
in the oceans phytoplankton having
bloomed uncontrollably might collapse
suddenly leading to a catastrophic
breakdown of the marine food web the
climate having cooled would now shoot in
the other direction without
phytoplankton to suck up CO2 triggering
a runaway global warming
event the global agricultural system
already reeling from pollinator collapse
and crop failures would have to adapt
yet again to a new set of challenges
healthc Care Systems worldwide already
burdened by AR rise in autoimmune
diseases would have to deal with a new
wave of viral illnesses and that's only
the beginning as far as us humans are
concerned Decades of viral mediated Gene
transfer has left all species including
us with reduced genetic diversity and
untrained immune systems especially for
the Next
Generation in the 1980s the hygiene
hypothesis was formulated that states
babies who aren't introduced to
pathogens will grow up with severely
weakened immune systems and at a greater
risk of allergies and other autoimmune
diseases it's the classic little dirt
never hurts anyone argument
reintroducing viruses into such a
population could be disastrous viruses
that were ons relatively harmless could
become lethal it would be reminiscent of
when the Spanish brought small pox to
the new
world if you thought Corona virus
wreaked havoc in 2020 just wait and see
what happens when a similar virus is let
loose on a population whose immune
systems have just awoken from a 100e
siesta okay so lastly I just want to
point out that a lot of the hyper tical
scenarios I mentioned in this video are
highly speculative despite being drawn
from current scientific understanding
did you know that viruses are by far the
most abundant biological entity on Earth
so trying to predict what would happen
if we removed them from our world and
then reintroduce them is such a dense
and complex task that there is literally
no supercomputer or AI model in
existence that could attempt to do it
for everything that is affected by
viruses biology the climate Evolution
there are are aund other contributing
factors and more
besides viruses are just too
intrinsically woven into the makeup of
our planet and our history and the
history of every living thing all I do
know is that we should wish for their
removal at our
Peril except for sasov that can off
thanks for watching thanks to fishing
class for sponsoring this video download
the game by using my link in the
description box or scan the QR code and
share your biggest catch in the pinned
comment